thank you so much all for being here
thank you Eric for the nice intro thank
you for remembering my rank within the
company I appreciate that
um so I don't have T-shirts for you but
I do have stickers I do have fling
stickers that I do have the bizm
stickers
um catch me after the talk for getting
some cool stickers all right so let's
get started um and to set this scene a
little bit
uh what I would like to talk about today
is uh real-time data and tools for
enabling you to benefit from real-time
data and why do I think this is a
worthwhile thing to talk about well I
think the world is real time right so
let's say you are in the business of
processing credit card credit card
transactions and you want to do some
sort of fraud detection maybe you do
some sort of analyzes hey this credit
card is used here in Austin right now
and in 30 minutes from now it's used
over in San Francisco by some supposedly
by another person right so this seems
seems fishy you want to be able to
detect this kind of pattern and you want
to maybe then lock down this credit card
in order to do this you need to have a
real-time data stream and by real time I
don't mean hard real time as in terms of
Computer Sciences was it guaranteed a
maximum latency but more like really you
know Snappy low latency near real time
so the world is real time and your data
streams they also should be real time to
enable you to implement those kinds of
use cases
because well as always your data gets
older and older
um the less value it has right so if you
do this sort of fraud detection tomorrow
well the guy who has the credit card
they might have uh done all kinds of
spending already it's just too late so
you want to have fresh data
um in order to to to react to this
now
today I want to talk about three part
icular patterns in the context of change
data streaming so this is about getting
changements out of a database something
like postgres something like my SQL
Oracle SQL Server
um and making use of those changements
and I want to talk in particular about
three different patterns three use cases
one is the outbox pattern which is about
propagating data changes across
microservices I want to talk about the
strength pattern which allows you to
move into a world for microservices
coming from a monolithic context and
lastly I want to talk about how you can
go and Implement order logs how can you
enrich your change around streams with
contextual metadata like what's the
business owner or business user who did
this specifically change this kind of
stuff
um Eric introduced me already so I don't
have to say too much
um but I want to touch a little bit on
yes for the last five years I worked on
division which is an open source tool
for change data capture I was the lead
of that and well I guess that's what
most people associate my work with
all right so let's let's talk a little
bit before we get to those use cases
let's talk a little bit about uh some of
the tools which can help us for
implementing those real-time
um data pipelines and the first one well
it is uh Division and what this is about
is it's about streaming changes out of a
database to your consumers and the way
this works is it Taps into the
transaction log of your database so all
of our databases
um they have a transaction log which
essentially means when transactions are
coming in writing transactions the
database will append events to this
transaction log and in that sense it's
the source of Truth for our system and
what the vision does is it gets to the
transaction lock extract changes so
whenever there's an insert or an update
or delete it will
capture that change and send it out to
your consumers typically this happens
via Apache Kafka as a streaming platform
so most of these musers I would say
they're also Kafka users but as we will
see in a bit if you use something like
Apache link
um you there's other means of using to
be easy and I will touch on this in a
bit
now I could do an entire division
project talk uh and this would be very
interesting on its own right but just uh
to set the scene here it's an entire
open source CDC platform so by open
source I mean it's apache2 license it's
not part of the Apache Foundation it's a
project which is primarily sponsored by
Reddit but it's in Apache License
project which means you can use it as
you please you can contribute you can
Fork it if you wanted to I don't like
YouTube but you could so you know
um you have all those Liberties you get
with open source and now it's an entire
platform for CDC so there is for
instance a notion of snapshotting this
means if you set up a new CDC connector
um you likely won't have the data from
last year in your transaction logs the
database will discard transaction logs
once it doesn't need them any longer for
its own purposes which would be
typically
um transaction recovery or replication
and at some point the database might
figure okay I discard this transaction
log which means we cannot just go to the
database and bootstrap the entire State
and this is where this notion of
snapshotting comes in the division can
scan entire tables in parallel
um also while reading the stream to the
transaction log to you know do a
backfill of the data you already have in
your database
um and let me also say there's a you
know large large production deployments
of this so um there's people who use uh
division to stream change out of
hundreds of databases so it's really a
battle proven I would say by the way who
uses division in production so like Eric
okay brave soul there's a few more all
right very good excellent I would like
to learn maybe after what you are doing
I'm very curious about it
cool
um
right so let's talk a little bit more
about those change events so how do they
actually look like and let me say well
that's obviously a Json representation
but really this is just one means of how
this change event is serialized right it
could also be serialized as ever or as
protocol buffers so the the seamless
format it could be anything but you know
to visualize it I I obviously use
something which is human readable
um and that's that's the semantical
structure of those Tradewinds so most
the most interesting part is uh what we
call those before and after
um parts of the change event so they
describe in case of an update event how
did this road this change when it's
about look before and after the change
and now within those two blocks before
and after the structure resembles your
table right so you have a field for each
column in your in the table you're
capturing
um so that's before and after now of
course is this if this is an insert
event where we just would have this
after part because there was no Old
State before an insert and vice versa if
it was a delete event we would just have
the before part and we would not have an
afterpark but for updates we have both
cool so that's the
data of the events themselves and then
there's some some metadata and this for
instance tells you what kind of
connection connector is this what
version timestamp when was this
transaction committed
does it originate from a snapshot all
kinds of stuff like you know what table
this is from and also what is the offset
in the transaction log so transaction ID
and in this case it's a postgres event
so we have this log sequence number
which tells you which is the position in
the source transaction log where this
event is coming from so you could use
this for instance later on for
deduplication or you know for reasoning
about the order of your events
and then there's also this up operation
discriminator which tells you okay this
is an update event could also be like a
great event delete event and so on
um right and that's that's this medical
structure of those events in terms of
Kafka
um if you are using Kafka value you
would
um know or you will know that there you
also have a message key which defines
how your events are
um ordered what are the ordering
guarantees and in terms of division the
message key in Kafka would be the
primary key of your table which means
all the change events which pertain to
the same record to the same purchase
order to the same customer
um and so on David go they would go into
the same
um partition in that Kafka topic which
means you will receive the change events
for the same customer for the same
purchase order in the exact correct
order so that's the message key
all right
in terms of how you could go and use the
business I mentioned most of the people
use it via Kafka connect
um or wire Kafka I should say and for
Kafka there's um so by the way who's
using Kafka
wow that's surprisingly few people okay
I like I thought like everybody would be
using Okay interesting so half of you
maybe
um so for those who are using Kafka they
will notice Kafka connect for those who
don't uh use Kafka I will tell you
there's Kafka connect and Kafka connect
is a runtime and a development framework
for connectors which either take data
into Kafka from an external system which
are Source connectors and now you might
guess it to beesium is essentially a set
of Kafka connect Source connectors in
this deployment mode so they take data
into Kafka and then you have sync
connectors which subscribe to those
topics get those changements out of
Kafka and then into an external system
so you could use this change of instant
to implement replication use cases put
put your data into elasticsearch to
enable full text search put your data
into snowflake uh pechippino if you have
data warehousing use cases or analytics
use cases so you could use those change
events for all those kinds of use cases
so that's Kafka connect
then we have What's called the embedded
engine and this means in this mode you
would use these with connectors as a
library within your jvm based
applications
um essentially you just register a
callback method which will then be
invoked by the embedded engine whenever
the change went and this is very
interesting for advanced integration use
cases so for instance for Apache link
there's a project called Flink CDC which
uses the the bezum embedded engine to
ingest change events directly into Flink
pipelines without having to go through
Kafka or other streaming platforms so
that's the embedded engine and then
well division started
um you know very closely related Apache
Kafka and still as I mentioned it is
mostly used with Kafka but in over time
people reached out to the community and
they said we liked beezum and we would
like to use it but we are maybe using
AWS Kinesis or Google Cloud Pub sub or
Apache Pulsar
um not um all kinds of provica all kinds
of alternative data streaming platforms
which are not Kafka
um and for those users we provide bizoom
server which essentially in your overall
architecture has the same role as Kafka
connect so it's the runtime for your
connectors but they give you
connectivity and the ability to send
those change events out while all those
um
data streaming platforms other than
Kafka
and the last thing I want to mention on
the Visa itself um I would and obviously
I'm biased right because I've been
working on it for so long but I would
argue it's becoming the de facto uh
platform or the defective standard for
CDC so and uh the reason why I'm saying
this is because also other vendors other
database uh implementers they hop onto
the train and Implement their CDC
connectors using DDP Zoom connector
framework so the first folks to do that
were the friendly folks from Sila TB
working on a nosql database which is a
via protocol compatible with Cassandra
and they decided they want to implement
their CDC connector based on division
which also means now that the users of
celadb and their CDC feature get the
same changement format as they would get
it from the other division connectors
for postgres my sequence on which means
for your consumers or if you implement
stream processing logic you don't have
to care does this event originate from
from which database you just can
implement this in a unified way and this
is why I find this very interesting that
folks like solar DB you get you gigabyte
and also Google cloud or Google they
decided to implement a CDC connector for
Google Cloud spanner based on the BSM
connector framework it's even part of
the museum project umbrella
um so you now also can use again the
division format with Google Cloud
spanner if this is your kind of thing
pretty cool all right
then let's talk a little bit about
Apache Flink so
um again to give some context there so
the business very interesting for
ingesting change events out of a
database and now when I say it enables
all those use cases like replication
updating your search index updating your
data warehouse I'm well maybe I'm lying
a little bit to you because it doesn't
do it by itself right because if you
have your data in Kafka you need to
still solve the second part of this
equation how do you take the data out of
Kafka
um and this is where you need to think
about sync connectors which division
itself doesn't concern with and also
maybe you just you don't want to take
your data just as is one one to one
maybe you want to massage it a little
bit you want to process it you want to
filter it you want to aggregate it again
this isn't something which division does
but this is something which Apache Flink
does and this is exactly where I think
those two projects taken together are
very interesting and are very very
powerful
um platform
and again Flink so who's using Flink
Eric you're using Flink okay I would
have been surprised if you didn't raise
your hand okay one brave soul is fling
okay so this is my mission to change
this so next time it should be these two
people
100 increase
um Flink so what is this about it's
about stateful stream processing so this
means
um you ingest data streams either from a
database as in the case of division but
it could also be click data from your
web application it could be sensor data
if you are in an iot scenario it ingests
all those data streams
um and you could have like hundreds of
thousands of or millions of events per
second so it's very scalable
it applies processing logic to those so
you could do simple stuff status stuff
like filtering mapping maybe like
reducing uh your messages like you know
cutting out some stuff but it also does
stateful stuff like joining operations
grouping operations aggregation
operations windowing operations it does
all that and it puts out those data
streams into other sync sync systems as
you if you want to say that
um so that's that's if Link in a
nutshell
and I feel I'm doing not completely
adjusted because it's a very powerful
complex streaming processing solution
but that's it on a on a high level
and now in terms of how you interact
with uh Flink um so I stole this slide
from my good friend martyr which I don't
believe is here but uh so she did have
the slide in her talk and I just stole
it because I really like it so if you
dive into Flink and you want to learn
more how you use I mean at the bottom of
it you have like you're building apps
building blocks of Primitives which you
know let you interact with State let you
reason about uh timestamps event time
all this kind of stuff State Stores
um you know those are fundamentals then
you have uh what they What's called the
data streaming API so that's an
imperative Java API
um you know which allows you to
implement your stream processing logic
in sort of like a fluent API way we will
see it in a bit later
based on tap and all this you know it it
increases the
um uh abstraction level and it gets
easier to use but at the same time it
also becomes maybe a bit less expressive
as you go up into this during the stack
so you have what's next called the table
API this is essentially about giving you
a relational representation of your data
and finally there's what's called fling
SQL so this allows it to apply stream
processing logic well using SQL and this
means now while using SQL this is open
to use by many more people who may not
necessarily be Java developers or Scala
developers you know but maybe they are
data engineers and they are a very good
SQL developers now with link SQL they
can benefit from Flink but of course
there's limitations so let's say you
couldn't maybe you want to reach out to
an external web service to implement
your um your streaming job well you
couldn't do this using fling SQL right
so you would have to use one of the
lower level apis
all right so let's let's talk a little
bit about out taking those two things
together division for CDC and appetitive
Link now in the simplest case well you
would just use or you could use it for a
pipeline like this right where you have
a Flink CDC connector by the way I
should save links you see it's it's a
side project
um or project from the
um Flink ecosystem which deals with
integrating CDC connectors like dbzm
into a flick so we could have if link
CDC connector we could have a gdpc sync
connector and we would just Implement a
very basic data
propagation pipeline I guess you could
call it
very often that's not enough right you
want to do more interesting things with
them maybe you want to filter your data
so common use case is data formats maybe
you want to you know adjust them to UTC
or just have a specific time format so
you could use that maybe you want to
mask sensitive data maybe you have
something which you don't want to expose
so you could use those stateless filter
map operators for those kinds of
operations encryption another nice use
case so that's stateless transformations
you could uh similarly you could
Implement routing so maybe based on the
context on the content of an event you
could route it to different things so
maybe you have a stream of purchase
order change where it's coming in and
now depending on the type of the
purchase order you want to send it to
different data stores on the thing side
so maybe you know B2B Autos should go
there b2c orders should go there so
that's routing
and of course it's not as I mentioned
limited to to JPC so there's a very rich
ecosystem of connectors
um on the source and on the sync side so
you have connectivity with elasticsearch
mongodb Pinot snowflake S3 and so on all
that wire patch of Link
all that is stateless so far and I guess
that also enrichment also would be still
stateless so um you know but maybe you
have your change Vents and they are not
like fully uh self-descriptive so maybe
they contain some sort of IDs which you
want to resolve into like a proper uh
business identifier or something like
that and this information is stored in
an external system so you could
Implement in some sort of enrichment use
case where you go to this external
system and resolve those IDs
so let's move on a little bit to
stateful operations so you could join
your stuff so maybe and for folks who
were my demo yesterday they saw that so
maybe you have uh
um an event stream via a Kafka so maybe
a purchase order is coming in Via Kafka
and you wanna again add some reference
data to this which you received via
links you see so you could implement the
sort of joining use case if link would
take care of keeping track of the state
making this fail tolerant and so on and
you could send it out to your consumers
all right so that's that's um you know
on a higher level a few things which you
can do in a rather abstract level I
guess which you can do by combining um
the museum and CDC with Flink now let's
talk a little bit about some more
specific use cases and they are
particularly uh in the context of
microservices so that's what I want to
focus on a little bit so let's talk a
little bit about the outbox pattern and
taking data or exchanging data between
different microservices so again a
specific more specific use case now in
the context of microservices now if you
think about microservices
um
the situation there is you want to
isolate your your the parts of your
domain right you want to make them that
they are mostly self-independent in
particularly in particular you don't
want your services to share databases
they should keep each should keep their
own State and you want to reduce the
amount of interactions between your
services
but still I would say you know they
don't exist in isolation as hard as you
try your service will need to interact
so let's say you have a service which
receives purchase orders this needs to
somehow notify a service which builds
your shipments and which sends out the
the shipments to your customers so their
service these Services they need to to
need to interact with each other
um and now the challenge there is well
as those Services themselves are not
stateless well typically needs to be
done is each service needs needs to
update its own local database so this
all the service needs to I don't know
persist this purchase order and then you
also want to send out this message to
your other services and on the first on
the surface you might think okay let me
just do this let me you know try and
commit a transaction to my database and
then let me send out an event to the
other services maybe via Kafka and the
problem there is that those two
resources a database and Kafka they
cannot participate in a shared
transaction so you know you don't have
XA semantics with Patrick Kafka this
means those two things they are not
guaranteed to happen atomically what
could happen is you commit your database
transaction but then you fail to send
out this event to the other services I
know maybe Network split or whatever
went wrong your service crashes
um and now your overall data state is
inconsistent and this is of course
something you want to avoid or maybe
even verse you send out the message to
the shipment service via Kafka but then
for whatever reason you fail to commit
your own local transaction which then
maybe means you know you have initiated
a shipment but you don't have track of
that order in your own database
obviously not a good situation
so how can we go and solve this and um
so exactly that's the situation I want I
mentioned right so you know doing this
kind of stuff dual rights trying to
apply
changes to the multiple resources which
don't share it with actually guarantees
it's Error prone then you should avoid
it
now if you think about it
they change their capture can help you
with us right because what we could do
is we could capture the changes from our
tables maybe I'll purchase all the table
and send those change events out to our
consumers and that's um so then we don't
have this do right aspect because when
we just update our database and the CDC
process would happen afterwards so we
avoid the consistency issue but we also
are at the risk of exposing our internal
data schema to the outside world because
well if we capture changes to the order
table or to the order line table well if
you do changes to those tables maybe we
you know we change column names or we
change types we add columns all those
changes are impacting our Downstream
services and this is something which we
don't really want right we want to
Shield our internal model from any
external consumers and this is exactly
where this outbox pattern helps us so
the idea there is if this order service
receives a transaction
it's updates it's uh own internal tables
so it would go and you know insert data
into the order table or the line table
and at the same time it would insert an
event into another table which is called
the outbox table and now this outbox
table this is essentially our messaging
channel to the outside world and
all this happens in a single transaction
so we don't have this dual right problem
right so either this transaction gets
committed so we apply our data changes
and we insert the outbox event or we
roll back this transaction so nothing
gets persisted so this happens
atomically and now we would use division
to capture the inserts into this outbox
table and it only would ever be inserts
because well we wouldn't ever we never
wanted wanted to update events after we
have produced them so we would capture
the inserts from this outbox table and
then we would use those outbox events
and and send them to our consumers
how could this outbox table look like
well here I like to think about it in
terms of domain driven design so you
know if you are familiar with that there
you have the notion of an Aggregate and
aggregate route something like a
purchase order something like a customer
and you could implement this based on
the semantics of the
um of domain driven design which means
in this outbox table you would have
stuff like what's the aggregate type so
is this outbox event about purchase
orders is it about customers and so on
which then for instance we could use to
you know derive the name of the Kafka
topic from that aggregate type so we
could use send we could
um send events to different topics per
aggregate type we have something like
the aggregate ID so that's the primary
key of our our data which we will use
for ordering semantics again you know
this will inform the Kafka message key
essentially we could have something like
event type which is about you know like
a fine grain type of event if this is an
older event is it like order created
online changed and so on and finally we
have this payload field and this is now
our message to contract with the outside
world so this is you know where we say
how does this event look like and very
importantly and for the for the sake of
the example you know here I use Json but
again it could be ever or could be
anything but most importantly this
contract which we use in this payload
column this is independent from the
internal table structure and they they
these two things can evolve
independently so for instance we could
you know rename columns in our internal
table model without uh you know changing
the name in the Json message which we
sent so we can evolve those things
separately and we in particular we can
evolve the outbox message contract with
backwards compatibility in mind
um
right so now I wanted to just briefly
mention how you know how how does this
relate to Flink and there's an
interesting use case there are an
interesting implementation alternative
of this outbox pattern and this is like
this so here I mentioned okay this is an
outbox table so we insert events into a
table but if we if we use postgres in
particular we could use a nice trick
there uh we have a function which is
called PG logical emit message and this
allows us to just send events into the
transaction log of the database so they
will never show up in any table in
postgres they will just be appended to a
transaction dock which is pretty much
what we want right we don't really need
a table with that we don't want to query
those outbox events in our database
itself we just use this mechanism to get
out those events by the transaction log
and this is exactly where those logical
decoding messages help us so we can
insert arbitrary content into the
transaction log
um you know there's a discriminator
outbox messages in this case and again
my payload
so we can use this with
um postgres and what I then can do with
Flink well I can ingest the changes from
there and this is where again this
project Flink CDC comes into the picture
because now here looking at this Java
data streaming API in Flink
um what I get from Flink CDC is a
post-crestic postgresql source which I
can use you know to connect to my host
connect to my database give my
credentials and so on
um and then I have what's called a
source function in terms of the data
stream API and this Source function
produces essentially events in this case
coming from this postgres database and
by the way this postgresql Z Source
that's exactly built on top of this
embedded engine which I mentioned
earlier
now I have the source function and then
you know I can use the data streaming
API to implement a very basic pipeline
where I would also set up a Kafka sync
specify my bootstrap server all this
kind of stuff
um I put those things together and well
you know I built up this pipeline in
particular I filter all the also those
events because here I'm just interested
in those events which have this
operation Type M so it's a logical
decoding message which are exactly those
events which we inserted to the
transaction log
um and I can now ingest those those
events
now there's one thing which I also need
to do I need to
um you know apply some sort of routing
logic to make
um sense out of those domain driven
design semantics which are mentioned and
this is what we see here so that's a
custom serializer so if I go back you
see it's you know this is used here so
we just apply this to every event which
comes into the stream and there
essentially we just say we wanna you
know customize how this um Kafka message
which we send out how this should look
like so in this case we do exactly what
I mentioned before we use the aggregate
type as the topic name we use the
aggregate ID as the Kafka message key
the propagate the payload as our Kafka
message value and then we also insert a
Kafka message header
um with the with a unique event ID which
consumers for instance could use for
deduplication I know it's quite a bit of
code and at the end I have a link where
you can you know download all the
example from GitHub and you can try it
out yourself
all right so that's the outbox pattern
let's talk a little bit about another
situation where you are not yet in a
world of microservice but you want to
move there and this is where this
Strangler fig pattern helps us and by
the way if you wonder why it's named
that way well this was or the term was
coined by Martin Fowler and apparently
he you know became aware of those
Strangler thick plants which grow around
an old tree strangle it until it dies
off and this is exactly what reminded
him apparently of the scenario where we
have a monolith which you want to you
know move to microservices step by step
why do we want to do this well uh if you
want to avoid Big Bang migrations right
so maybe we have a large model list we
want to split it up into 10
microservices and we don't want to do
all this all at once because it might be
too risky for us to do it
um instead we want to you know do uh
things we want to take things step by
step and extract one service or maybe
functionality of One servers one step at
a time maybe pause
um and all this kind of stuff and this
is what this pattern is about
so and this is how it looks like so
let's say we have you know a legacy
application maybe Java sticks a very old
version of spring and um this is our
monolithic application and now I would
argue yes it's a it's a deployment
monolith but most of the times you still
have some sort of structure there right
I mean I have never seen really this
case where everything talks to
everything it's like a huge big ball of
one maybe I've been happy I don't know
but usually I feel there is a structure
of components which you can find in
monolith now let's say we want to take
one of the components from this models
and extract it into a new service
First Step would be to add a routing
component in front of this so something
like nginx Envoy whatever products you
want to do
um ha prophecy
you put this in front so you are able to
Route requests different kinds of
requests to different uh targets there
so we would you know we put this in
front and then we would add and uh start
and extract a new service so maybe we
want to take this owner's component from
this uh monolith and move this into a
new service maybe this also uses another
database mongodb so we would use the
museum to set up a change event flow
because for now we would still keep all
the right access to this to this
application to the model this but then
we would propagate the changes to the
owner's domain over to this mongodb uh
instance we would have the sync which
applies the changes there and now our
routing component would make sure that
maybe initially just some reads are
served by a new service and here for the
sake of the example again you know I've
used different stack workers new Java
version and maybe we just have a single
read View which we have in this new
service and we would use the proxy to
write to Route the reads to that service
um you know to round some reads to that
new service and it would have the data
by means of setting up the CDC stream
now we could uh you know keep moving
forward with this migration and we could
also say at some point maybe everything
which pertains to the owner's domain all
this is now owned by this new
microservice so this is entirely gone
from the monolith meaning also all the
rights will now be routed to the new
microservice so we you know that would
be good but the challenge there is well
maybe you have other parts in the domain
of Demands which also need to have
um access to owner's data for I don't
know maybe for doing some some reads in
the other components or for resolving
some references and so now what you
could do is you could set up a CDC flow
in the other direction which propagates
owner changes back to the monolith so
you could resolve those references
um but you just should be careful of for
each part of your domain like you know
component or maybe even a table you
should always have one uh one component
who is in charge so you don't you
shouldn't have rights for owners on both
sides because then you would end up
propagating you know the same changes
probably fourth and back in an infinite
Loop so that's what you not want to do
so that's uh you know how you how you
could go about such a migration again
there's a demo repo where you can find
out uh more about this and you can play
with that but let me touch a little bit
on some of the challenges
um
again we have this question so don't be
a leak information
um because well if you just capture our
our tables as they are
um you know maybe we don't want to
impact our new microservices with all
the minutiae of the old model maybe we
had limitations in terms of how long can
column names be their own we used some
awkward data types we don't want to use
we don't want to expose all those
Oddities to our new microservices so
that's a question how can we isolate
those things and maybe we also want to
think about aggregating data Maybe in
particular if you use a document store
like mongodb instead of having data in
multiple tables maybe you want to we
want to join it and aggregate it and put
it into a single document in in such a
document store
and this is again where Flink would help
us so let's let's go there so we could
have a Flink application which for
instance you know does filtering does
sanitization of column names
um massaging data types all this kind of
stuff and also joining and this is um
you know this is an example how this
could look like so by default if we had
an owner's table in the pets table we
would have this data on multiple change
streams but maybe this is how we would
like to have this data in mongodb in a
single document so if you want to join
the data from those topics owners and
pets and we want to aggregate it per
customer per owner and put it into a
single document
and to do this um well we could again
use Flink and and Flink CDC and now I
mentioned there's different apis in
inflink for
um implementing your logic so I showed
you the data streaming API I also want
to show you the uh um the fling SQL API
or yeah fling SQL
um and the way you would interact there
is well with SQL so you would say you
know something like create table which
essentially represents a source Stream
So you say this is uh of the connector
type my SQL CDC again you give your
credentials
um and this gives you now a stream or a
representation of this data in in in
Flink and you could then use fling SQL
to reason about multiple of those
streams so here uh you know don't be too
intimidated what I'm just doing there is
essentially I just join multiple of
those tables and then I use a few custom
functions to essentially aggregate those
function those those data per per owner
and put it out in to another table why I
just insert into statement at the top
um you know so just to give your
intuition you can Implement those use
cases also in terms of SQL in a purely
declarative fashion
all right so by the way how much time do
I have left
seven minutes okay that's pretty cool
all right cool so then uh let me talk
about one more use case and this is um
building audit logs so
the the motivation there as well you
have those change event streams and you
saw those change events with the before
and the after part and you know some
kind of technical metadata like what's
my table what's my connector timestamps
transaction ID and so on but at the same
time uh this stream of changements is
lacking some more higher level business
oriented metadata so typically you want
to have something like what's the
business user who did a particular
change maybe you want to have like a use
case identifier or like client uh device
information client IP this kind of stuff
and you you don't store this sort of
information in your business tables
right so the change events which
division or any CDC tool can get out of
your tables they would lack this sort of
higher level business uh business
oriented metadata and again we can use
stream processing to enrich our change
events
um with this metadata now the question
is where is this metadata coming from
and again we could use you know we could
insert metadata into another table we
could then join this uh those table
streams but here and by I guess by now
you realize I'm a fan of postgres and
I'm a fan of logical decoding again we
can use this function PG logical limit
message
to insert this metadata at the beginning
of each transaction so in this case we
say and by the way this true parameter
says that's a transactional message so
this means this only gets written out if
this transaction gets committed
otherwise it would not show up any log
we say it's of a specific type audit
metadata and again our payload here you
know that's the metadata which we want
to put into our changements and we do
this once at the beginning of each
transaction so there we would use you
know we add our business user and all
this kind of stuff so that's a specific
operation which we do from our
application
and then we do we do this Arrangement
part and um
so this is how it could look like so you
know if I have a transaction flow
um I do my begin at the very first uh
the very first thing I do for each
transaction is I I call this function to
provide my my custom metadata then I do
whatever data changes I want to do I do
an insert into customers addresses and
so on and then I commit it
um so that's that's my my raw uh change
when stream and what I would like to do
is I would like to take this metadata
and put it into each of my change events
and coming back to this data streaming
API there I could use what's called this
flatmap operator so this essentially
allows me for each event which comes in
to emit uh zero up to n event so I could
say I want to discard an event I want to
you know ingest one event and amid one
event or I can emit multiple events and
I use this flatmap operator
um to implement essentially a logic
which goes like that so if my event
which comes in
is such an audit metadata event which I
recognize because test is up Type M and
it's of the type the prefix is ordered
then I take this metadata and put it
into some state store so this link
allows me to you know keep state so I
put it there and then when my when
another change when it comes in which
isn't such a metadata event
then I will go to my state store I will
look up uh you know is this the same
transaction still and if it is I take
the metadata from the state store and
put it into my changement so that's
that's the high level intuition of this
logic
um and again there um you know I have an
example for all of this on GitHub
all right and that's
what I want
um
make the case well a yes you know this
notion coming back to the beginning this
notion of real-time data of having fresh
data this is uh becoming more and more
um critical
um you know it allows you to just react
to to your data with a very low latency
and you know again there's all kinds of
use cases so for instance if you do a
dashboarding maybe with Apache Pino
um you want to have fresh metadata on
such a dashboard right or data on such a
dashboard you want you don't want to
have old data so you want to have fresh
data and in the context of uh databases
and ingesting changes out of those
databases to bzoom is a very powerful
open source tool which gives you this
just to give you one example I know of
users who do CDC pipelines from division
MySQL cluster of my SQL database into
Google bigquery for their analytics
purposes and they have an end-to-end
latency of less than two seconds so
within less than two seconds after
something has changed in the operational
database they have this data in the in
in their analytics platform so they can
run well I would say real-time Analytics
combining this with Flink
um you know takes it to the next level
right so we can do all those kinds of
things like filtering massaging our data
joining it
um or windowing I mean I didn't speak
about windowing but you know we can do
straight stateful stream processing in
all kinds of shapes and forms using
Flink upon those types of events and
lastly if you want to learn more so I
just wrote an article for infoqueue.com
where you which is called the wonders of
postgres logical decoding messages where
you can learn a little bit more about
how you can go about those uh PG logical
emit function um
PG logical message function and how you
can use this how you can process those
changes with Flink so you can find
there's an info queue and you also can
find on the decodable
um GitHub organization you can find the
source code of that and with that I'm
done you can hit me up on Twitter you
can hit me up via email and of course
you also can come I should say that I
should you can come by our booth you can
grab some stickers you can ask questions
to well Eric are you there I don't know
I don't know but maybe you know our
staff at the booth and we can talk about
Flink Division and everything in between
thank you so much
thank you